le procès est ce que ça pose un problème
ça pose aucun problème parce que la
déposition des parties civiles et de
droit mais n'est pas du tout obligatoire
donc c'est libre à elle de s'exprimer ou
pas et il ya de nombreuses parties
civiles qui n'ont pas souhaité ou pas pu
aussi pour des raisons matérielles qui
habitent loin et qui n'ont pas voulu
parce que raconter c'est revivre aussi
forcément il y en a certaines pour qui
c'est insupportable autres qui au
contraire ressentent le besoin absolu de
témoigner
les deux attitudes sont sans voix quand
à fait louable et légitime jean louis
périès qu'est le président de la cour a
décliné la demande d'anonymisation de
certaines parties civiles pour quelles
raisons alors en effet lors l'huile et
l'a très bien expliqué il a expliqué que
le d'abord c'était l'oralité des débats
qui avait là aussi la webradio donc il
fallait que tout le monde sache qui
était en train de parler et pour le
respect du contradictoire
chacun devait savoir à qui ils avaient
affaire donc il a demandé aux victimes
de décliner leur identité
ce qui est intéressant d'ailleurs c'est
que les victimes qui avaient fait la
demande de
il ya quelque chose d'assez particulier
dans ce procès que j'ai jamais vu avant
à ce niveau là c'est que parmi les
parties civiles il y à des
professionnels s'étaient certains
policiers certains gendarmes qui étaient
sur les lieux se sont constitués partie
civile ce qui de mon point de vue le
post question d'une question de statut
pour quelles raisons
si oui quand vous êtes policier dans
l'exercice de vos fonctions
vous faites votre boulot voilà alors là
évidemment c'est très particulier on
peut comprendre mais bon de mon point de
vue certaines parties s'il tire un peu
sur la ficelle mais peu importe et
certaines de ses parties civiles
professionnelles avait demandé à
témoigner sous le couvert de l'anonymat
ce qui est une demande légitime
enquêteurs pour un enquêteur ces deux
droits un enquêteur dans ces affaires de
terrorisme peut témoigner de manière
anonyme donc visage flouté
éventuellement voix déformée là c'est le
présent a dit non vous devez dire qui
vous êtes et demandé à la presse qui
reste libre de on est pas le président
n'a pas d'ordre à nous donner mais vous
dis je pense que la presse peut
comprendre et ne n'est pas obligé de
donner votre identité je supporte plus
évidemment ça ne pose aucun problème
c'est assez victime ou ses proches des
victimes de préciser en amont de leur
témoignage elle ne souhaite pas que la
presse reprennent leur mois là mais si
on veut témoin hier identité en tant que
victime à ce procès et ont dit qu'ils
ont de quoi on a été victime et où est
ce que les accusés normalement présents
dans le box qui sont normalement au
nombre de quatorze peuvent refuser
d'assister à ces auditions
les accusés n'ont pas le droit de
refuser d'assister à leur propre procès
peut-être la présence de l'accusé aux
assises est obligatoire il n'y a pas
d'exception alors évidemment après il ya
des preuves qui peuvent se poser si un
accusé est on vraiment gravement malade
pourquoi une crise d'appendicite
d'opérations péritonite pas quoi là il
ya un cas de force majeure mais qui met
la cour d'en bas ont peur des solutions
techniques nous avons peu de disjoindre
sont cassés à le mettre de côté le g
plus tard et par ailleurs si un accusé
se comporte mal qu'est ce que je parlais
tout à l'heure des attentats 95 et le
président est obligé de l'expulser c'est
aussi très embêtant parce qu'il faut lui
faire tous les soirs à compte rendu de
ce qui s'est passé dans la journée donc
le greffier va en cellule et lui fait un
résumé de
des positions du jour mais alors
évidemment si c'est des victimes on peut
dire on a entendu une telle et telle et
telle personne ça c'est con c'est pas
très compliqué mais si cd des experts
des choses comme ça il faut faire des
résumés vraiment assez précis que
l'accusé doit savoir ce qui s'est dit à
son procès pourquoi est ce que c'est si
important d'entendre les victimes et de
multiplier l'audition des témoignages on
sait qu'il va y en avoir 14 15 par jour
jusqu'au 29 octobre en quoi ces
témoignages sont essentiels en ce sens
que le jugement n'est peut-être rendu
sans eux
alors je vais essayer de répondre sans
choquer
certains
c'est essentiel pour les victimes parce
que les victimes ont besoin de dire
publiquement celles qui décident de
parler mais comme là on l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans certaines ne veulent pas
venir et ça ne gêne pas tout aurait pu
refuser de venir donc certains certaines
victimes ont besoin de raconter ce qui
leur est allé leur souffrance et c'est
très légitime d'autres non
d'un point de vue judiciaire
il ya deux sortes de victimes il ya les
victimes témoins et les victimes pas
témoins les victimes témoins ont un
intérêt judiciaire supplémentaires
puisqu'elles vont révéler des choses qui
se sont vraiment passé d'autres vont
parler de leur douleur personnelle
familiale bon professionnel mais c'est
autre chose donc c'est pas essentiel
d'un point de vue strictement judiciaire
pour la manifestation de la vérité
puisque on sait ce qui s'est passé mais
il n'y a pas de mystère tellement sur
cette enquête on sait qui a fait qui n'a
pas fait bon et en même temps c'est
malgré tout ça reste un moment
extrêmement important puisque
surtout en matière de crimes terroristes
et le crime terroriste par définition
vise toute la société et c'est important
aussi pour l'histoire qu'on entende les
répercussions est très spécifique de la
tuerie de masse sur les victimes
directes les victimes du premier cercle
et après bon on s'éloigne mais les
dommages collatéraux et les dommages
collatéraux mais ils sont quand même
consubstantiel de crimes terroristes
c'est aussi évidemment une de ses
spécificités c'est que il ya le crime de
l'immédiat le crime pour le terrible
pour l'emploi 130 victimes vous imaginez
le nombre de gens qui ont été
directement impactés par ça et puis même
pour la société il ya un traumatisme
énorme et donc ce défilé de victimes qui
est très long
qui pose des facto un problème
d'équilibré de l'audience puisque ça
pèse énormément dans un procès classique
vous avez une famille partie civile oui
c'est face à un accusé ment là c'est
compliqué mais
ça a son importance a son importance qui
au delà de judiciaire strict pour
l'histoire puisque will ce procès est
enregistrée pour l'histoire assure ça
c'est essentiel ici oui pour ne laisser
une trace on l'a vu on l'a vu au procès
qui a eu lieu il ya un an de 10 de
charlie mais qui était aussi la tuerie
de lumière cacher et de et le crime de
montrouge
les témoignages de victimes
indéniablement apporté quelque chose on
a d'ailleurs on a eu du mal à s'en
remettre c'était c'était terrible
terrible terrible je disais vous suivez
ce portrait ce procès pardon depuis le 8
septembre dernier jour de son ouverture
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus frappé
stéphane durand souffland depuis le
début de ce procès
paradoxalement ce qui m'a le plus frappé
c'est que ça se passe bien cercle n'y a
pas eu de
d'abord c'est ballot mais l'organisation
a été très en amont par les autorités
judiciaires qu'on met en place un
dispositif en énorme mais qui reste
fluide donc ça c'est déjà bien joué
parce que c'était pas gagné d'avancé
contre les conditions de travail de la
presse en plus on va dire plus que
convenable
reconnaître salle à la presse judiciaire
l'association de la presse judiciaire
avait été associé de près à tout la mise
en place et ça ça se sent assez bien
fait tout ça c'est bien fait ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose je
dirais que en ce début de procès puisque
on est quand même ça prendra au moins
neuf mois on parle de femmes aiment et
ça va être peut-être débordé
c'est l'attitude de salles abdeslam que
malgré tout qu'ils restent l'accusé
qu'on scrute le plus parce que c'est le
seul qui était le membre des commandos
qui n'a pas été tué par la police
on nous avait dit que c'était un
hongrois un crétin de l'onu fout
en fait il n'a pas l'air fou au sens
psychiatrique du terme et il n'a pas
l'air crétins et il a une attitude
[Musique]
assez étonnante j'irai dans ces procès
lèvres en général les processeurs ils
sont assez décevants d'un point de vue
de
6 pour un chroniqueur judiciaire ça ne
s'est pas les plus intéressants raconté
très peu de dialogues entre le box et le
reste de la salle et lui lit là il a
fait une espèce de déclaration
liminaire en expliquant que bas que tout
ça c'était logique que c'était la
réponse aux crimes contre les musulmans
et paix dans l état islamique et que
voilà une forme de l'assumer ce rôle de
combattant de l'edf c'est ainsi qu'il
s'est présenté c'est assez intéressant
c'est dur à entendre évidemment mais en
même temps ça au moins ça a le mérite de
la franchise et et on sait qu'ils ont à
faire cette fois ci
si vous venez nous rejoindre en direct
sur figaro l'avait sur le chat youtube
la chaîne youtube figaro live merci de
nous suivre en direct ce matin nous
sommes en présence de stéphane durand
souffland journaliste chroniqueur
judiciaire au figaro
7 hier qu'ont débuté les premières
audiences des parties civiles au procès
du 13 novembre elles vont durer jusqu'à
fin octobre une succession de
témoignages des victimes aux proches des
victimes on essaye ce matin de décrypter
les enjeux de ces témoignages et puis
aussi évidemment vous l'avez entendu
l'émotion qui pèsent sur ces audiences
quand on lit vos papiers stéphane durand
souffland on est souvent à la limite du
supportable je pense à ces témoignages
de policiers qui sont entrés les
premiers au bataclan qu'on a pu entendre
enfin que les journalistes ont pu
entonner que la cour a pu entendre les
précédentes semaines cette limite elle
est quotidiennement atteinte et elle
sera certainement dans les semaines qui
arrivent pour les victimes on sait on
imagine c'est une très douloureux mais
pour vous le journaliste qui est
chroniqueur judiciaire vous avez suivi
bien d'autres procès certes mais on
imagine qu on ne sort pas indemne d'un
procès comme celui ci un procès inédit
par sa forme sa durée le nombre de
victimes on rappelle 130 morts comment
vous appréhendez vous ces cinq semaines
à venir d'audition
comment est-ce que vous gardez votre
votre place de journaliste je dirais et
le recul nécessaire pour ne pas flancher
c'est difficile de répondre à ça ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que après le
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
dont charly père caché à montrouge
quand ça s'est arrêté c'était très très
dur les témoignages on a entendu des
rescapés le charlie des survivants de
l'hyper cacher c'était vraiment très
très très dur et sur le moment on
écrivait et je pense que j'en déjà en
écrivant un article on évacue beaucoup
en tout cas une partie du de ce qu'on a
encaissés mais quand ça c'est fini on
s'est rendu compte qu'ils pensent un peu
tous que quand même ça a été plus dur
que d'habitude j'ai une seule référence
de trucs vraiment à la limite du
supportable c'est le procès de michel
fourniret notoire en série à l'époque
était qui nous a mis dans un écrin avait
duré deux mois et qui nous a tous
laissés dans un état
d'hébétude
donc charlie ça a été très très dur là
on s'attend au pire alors peut-être que
comme on s'attend au pire on sera mieux
armé pour rester sachant que notre
traumatisme évidemment rien comparé à
celui de des proches de victimes qui ont
perdu un proche et ont du mal à s'en
remettre ou de grands blessés enfin bon
c'est pas la même chose mais c'est quand
même divisée d'ailleurs ça a été
anticipé puisque il y a dans la salle en
permanence des psychologues qui sont là
on annonce est habile on est habitué
maintenant à en voir dans des affaires
un peu dur voilà la disposition des
victimes justement pour charlie
dix étaient là et là pour la première
fois
nous avons accès la presse a accès aux
outils ses besoins au soutien
psychologique côté on va voir si c'est
l'accumulation évidemment qui est aussi
parce qu on est
on est des journalistes on a parfois
mauvais esprits et on fait parfois de
l'humour pas très raffiné mais il ya des
moments on n'a vraiment pas envie de
rire et on encaisse comme on encaisse on
encaisse on encaisse on entend on voit
les gens qui pleurent on entend les gens
qui hurlent dans la salle qui partent
précipitamment et quand on va voir ça
peut être très bien se passer mais
disons plus rond au moins on est pris on
s'est préparé à quelque chose tous le
très difficile comment vous travaillez
vous avez évoqué le fait que vous
écriviez au sortir du tribunal est ce
que vous prenez des notes est ce que
vous avez le droit d'enregistrer est-ce
que vous finissez peut-être votre papier
dans les murs du tribunal ou alors vous
rentrez chez vous dans un contexte
solucom a enregistré c'est totalement
défendu enregistrement de son une image
si on se fait prendre c'est très
embêtant
nom prend des notes enfin moi j'en prend
mon poing des notes et puis après ben le
papier est criant dans l'enceinte du
palais de justice dans le meilleur des
cas dans les locaux la presse judiciaire
à un petit bureau que j'aime bien un peu
vieillot
j'ai mes habitudes je tiens juste à côté
de la salle d'audience parfois il est
écrit sur les nous sur leur dire dans la
salle d'audience parce que il ya eu un
témoignage qu'on n'a pas voulu rater
mais bon il ya le bouclage et on essaye
de faire au mieux ces des conditions un
peu souvent acrobatique mais moi j'aime
bien ça alors on le disait à l'émotion
est omniprésente à ce procès vous y
avait d'ailleurs consacré un papier que
vous avez conclu par on ne rend pas la
justice les yeux baignés de larmes
comment l'émotion peut-elle rester à sa
place lors d'un tel procès alors ça
c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué puisque la dir bala énormément
de victimes
le président envoie le calendrier a
décidé de
pas de commencer par ça d'ailleurs on
peut le noter a commencé par des points
dans quête les enquêteurs de venir aux
victimes en deux dans un deuxième temps
donc pas
inauguré voyez le cette espèce de deux
procès qu'on ne connaît pas encore n'a
jamais eu de procès comme ça donc pas
par les victimes et commencer par les
enquêteurs maintenant on a les victimes
qui vont nous prendre un mois mais
finalement c'est qu'un mois parmi neuf
et c'est vrai que c'est un problème
l'émotion dans la justice parce que
l'intimé conviction c'est pas la team
émotions et puis évidemment que cette
émotion nous submerger et nous
bouleverse et qu'on a envie ses victimes
pour après se lever souvent et on a
envie de les prendre dans nos bras
indien pauvre ami cc on est avec vous il
faut pas et il faut l'entendre et puis
après au moment de mon moment de juger
mais ça c'est pas le boulot des
journalistes c'est le boulot des
magistrats professionnels puisque c'est
une cour spécialement composée en
matière de terrorisme ce sera à eux de 2
10 rebonds on a eu cette émotion
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on a contre les
accusés quelles sont les charges qui
pèsent c'est ça qui compte les faits les
faits les charges l'épreuve
on a parlé un de cet homme qui préside
la cour jean-louis périès
c'est le président de cette cour
d'assises spéciale qui est cet homme
comment est il arrivé à présider cette
cour d'assises et à se retrouver à
diriger toutes ces auditions jusqu'à
jusqu'à fin mai alors le président
périès est magistrat très expérimentée
elle avait été jugé d'instruction il a
fait les jirs la juridiction
inter-régionale spécialisée qui qui
traite les grosses affaires de crimes
organisés pour faire simple et ensuite
il était président de cour d'assises
dans le ressort de la cour d'appel de
paris c'est lui alors je sais pas
comment 6,6 assez bousculé pour présider
ce procès c'est pas sûr
il a eu un an je crois plein à temps
plein mais il n'a fait que ça pendant un
an c'est un dossier il ya un million de
pages du dossier bon il ya deux toutous
dans ses pages mais c'est impossible
énorme il faut noter qu'il est entouré
il a deux assesseuses qui sont toutes
les deux présidents de cours d'assises
dont une que je connais bien et madame
simeoni qui est une très bonne
présidente de cour d'assises
l'ancienne juge d'instruction aussi
haineux qu'il m'aide à malines que je ne
connais pas mais qu'à brno réputation
donc ce qu'on a quand même trois
présidents de cours d'assises plein pot
ce qui est rare en général dans les
acides ya un présent d'assises et des
assesseurs qui font autre chose en
attendant le tribunal on peut dire que
ce sont des gens excessivement capter
ils sont voilà savent savent gérer et
s'il y en un qui défaille il reprend le
ralliement les relais assister et même
psychologiquement s'appelle donc pour
l'instant de prise en période on n'a pas
vu vers ce qu'on a vu pour l'instant
c'est beaucoup d'exercices de la police
de l'audience l'anonymat est-ce qu'il
faut l'anonymat des victimes est ce
qu'il faut voir telle ou telle vidéo
est-ce qu'il faut donner maintenant ou
pas la parole aux accusés est ce que les
parties civiles doivent poser leurs
questions avant ou après le ministère
public pour l'instant il a géré tout ça
je dois dire avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de maestria une espèce
d'autorité un peu des bonheurs enfin
c'est pas du tout visiblement un
pape et c'est qu'il est plutôt en
rondeurs mais en même temps très décidés
et pour l'instant ce début de procès il
n'y a pas eu d'anicroches quel est son
rôle précisément en définitive pas le
rôle du président il est capital dans un
procès cellule d'abord il a c'est lui
qui a fixé le calendrier pas lui qui
choisit les témoins lui ça c'est lui n'a
rien à faire là dedans c'est les partis
qui font cité et lui il a fixé le
calendrier donc c'est lui qui appelle
dans l'ordre les
témoins les parties civiles les experts
c'est lui qui pose les premières
questions internes a donc il va orienter
forcément un peu le questionnement dans
telle ou telle direction ensuite de quoi
il passe il propose à ses assesseurs
enfin il ya les deux principaux 1105 je
crois dans une cour d'assises
spécialement composée
à poser des questions donc on a déjà vu
que les deux assesseuses principal pose
des questions également ensuite
ministère public ils sont trois
et le président en fait c'est le c'est
vraiment le
rôle particulier la foire mythe
réacteurs mais
c'est le garant de la bonne marche des
prix bas de la butte c'est lui qui
coupent les micros quand tel ou tel y'a
pas que les accusés qui font des
remarques intempestives donc lui coupent
les micros comme tu l'as sélectivement
si on vous coupe ce qu'on voit bien
c'est la perspective est bonne à dire
que nous la presse on est assis à peu
près là où il ya les gendarmes de boules
mais le son très loin très loin par
rapport à nous très très loin et le box
que sur la gauche nous par exemple quand
on aime on la presse et de ce côté on
les voit pas on voit des voix un peu les
verts ont pape des slams par exemple qui
est le plus près de la cour ne voit pas
il trop loin donc le président c'est le
grand ordonnateur de tout ça il veille à
ce que tout se déroule bien il doit
gérer aussi les moments il va gérer les
moments d'intenses émotions ce qui va
forcément avoir les témoins des parties
civiles qui 11 s'est effondré
manière ou d'une autre ça va être à lui
de ménager les suspensions de voir que
ça roule vraiment c'est très très
intenses d'entre nous on demande une
suspension d'audience pendant quelques
minutes oui il ya des moments il faut
suspendre on peut pas en termes quand on
va avoir les journées où il y aura douze
ou quinze partie sud je pense qu'à
certains moments en principe la
suspension c'est vers 16 heures touré le
doubs c'est une journée contre une
petite suspension mais il ya peut-être
des moments où après un témoignage
terrible oui on pourra arrêter un peu
quoi qu'on reprenne son souffle
on parlait du box des accusés les
accusés justement qui pourraient se
murer dans le silence et n'a porté
aucune explication aux victimes qui
attendent justement ces victimes d'un
tel procès dans ce cas là je pense que
la tante des victimes vis-à-vis des
accusés d'une manière générale est assez
ambiguë est paradoxal
on attend des vies des accusés qui
disent la vérité enfin puisque on part
du principe qu'ils ont toujours menti je
sais à gros traits mais ça brille ça et
quand ils disent leur vérité quand ça
arrive
ça ne satisfait pas pape concorde des
slams dit je suis un membre de des je
suis un combattant belges pensent que ça
leur fait du mal d'entendre ça mais oui
qu'on m'attendait j'ai bien pour ça
qu'il a fait ça je pense pas qu'on
attend de ces accusés là en tout cas ce
dont on peut penser qu'ils ont vraiment
mis la main dans la préparation des
regrets des excuces c'est un peu un
possible parce que si vous êtes capable
de présenter des excuses après avoir
fait ça paradoxalement ça veut dire que
vous auriez été incapable de le faire et
c'est un crime beaucoup trop gros pour
attendre des remords quand on fait ça
c'est qu'on est parti dans une autre
dimension qu'on est d'accord pour tuer
des gens indistinctement ça veut dire
qu'ils peuvent être totalement même un
sensible aux témoignages qui vont se
succéder pour toi mais je pense que je
pense c'est mon sentiment que salle
abdeslam en tout cas ces témoignages qui
se succèdent
lagaf' pas parce que il est dans le box
mais parce que on ne parle pas des
victimes de l'état islamique sait s'ils
sont chez son truc alors les autres
c'est plus compliqué puisque dans
l'ensemble si on a compris tout se sont
pas exprimés très clairement mais on a
cru qu'on rendre que les autres accusés
elle est tenté de minimiser leur
participation le dire oui je fournis une
voiture mais je ne savais pas pourquoi
c'était faire donc eux ils sont
évidemment ils peuvent dire on est
désolé pour ce qui est arrivé ils sont
pas dans la même de la même démarche
apprend les croupes mai mais le
l'attendent delà des victimes vis-à-vis
des accusés est toujours mais je pense
en tout cas elle est très rarement
satisfaite parce que six exclus on va
dire qu'il est hypocrite six excuses
après on va dire qu'il a un coeur de
pierre seel disent les féroé d'axalot
s'il disait pas fait on va dire que
c'est un menteur la position de l'accusé
de manière générale et est compliquée
aux assises alors là elle est vraiment
très très compliqué et pour les victimes
c'est la plupart du temps c'est assez
inaudibles
beaucoup considèrent que c'est le procès
du siècle qu'est ce qui lui confère
cette dimension vous savez ça les procès
du siècle et procès historique en jeu
c'est quand c'est fini et je pense que
c'est une erreur de laquelle
l'institution judiciaire d'ailleurs à
participer de dire dès avant qu'ils
commencent que ce serait le procès d'un
procès historique pour nous avait dit de
la même chose pour le procès dit charly
le procès dit charlie on verra quand il
sera regardée par les historiens dans 50
ans pour moi c'est pas très historique
car on va revenir là dessus mais sur les
coûts il était d'accusé il était à peu
près pareil 14 et trois quarts n'ont pas
été retenus pour des faits terroristes
sont sortis du terrorisme
c'était vraiment des seconds couteaux
part peut-être deux ou trois qui ont été
plus lourdement condamné le dossier
était objectivement
pas terrible là c'est différent là on a
des accusés compter profile déjà
beaucoup plus intéressant donc
inquiétant on a un dossier qui est
apparemment très bien fait donc on va
voir on verra quand ça sera fini on
verra le verdict donc on comparera le
verdict à ce qu'on a entendu on verra si
c'est historique mais il est historique
c'est le crime cathy storyciens après le
procès la hauteur du lieu du crime
qu'est-ce qu'on peut préciser comme
autres grandes étapes à venir après ces
auditions des parties civiles des
victimes ou proches des victimes
d'autres semaine vont s'enchaîner avec
d'autres grandes étapes on imagine qui
aura évidemment les interrogatoires des
accusés bah oui parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que c'est quand même le procès
des accusés c'est pas le procès des
victimes et c'est pas c'est pas une
salle de catharsis non plus c'est ça qui
est très dur c'est que c'est le procès
des accusés donc de après les donc à la
fin du mois de octobre on va reprendre
début novembre et on va voir les accuse
d interrogatoire de personnalité des
accusés c'est alors ce sera françois
hollande qui devrait témoigner le 10
novembre bernard cazeneuve le 17
novembre manuel valls et manuel valls et
jean yves le drian sont évidemment aussi
et son pardon convoqué le 30 mars pour
ce qui les concerne je veux dire très
personnellement oui ça m'intéresse que
très moyennement ce qu'ils ont à nous
dire pourquoi on les fait intervenir
j'en sais rien pareil est ce que c'est
par rapport à ça pour faire un point sûr
que c'est un procès historique enfin
l'ancien président de la république et
ses ministres
peut-être que leurs témoignages seront
très intéressants moi j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont déjà tout dit tout dire
redire dit qu'ils vont pour certains
peut-être en profiter pour
se faire mousser devant le parce que
après évidemment il y aura les caméras
pour les interviewer moi j'attends rien
de enfin deux en tout cas voilà je parte
pas en me disant ah là là faut surtout
pas que je rate audience de willa
holland ça va être ça va être ma
meilleure audience de chroniqueur
judiciaire j'ai quelques mon petit doigt
me dit que non alors après il ya
sûrement avoir des avocats de parties
civiles qui vont faire les malins ces
essayant de le coincer le président sur
ce qui la fait pas fait d'expérience on
verra ce que ça donne mais pour coincer
un ancien président de la république ou
un ministre du calibre de d'un le drian
ou d'un cazeneuve je connais pas
beaucoup d'avocats qui sont capables de
le faire parce qu'on s'est passé des
nuits entières à négocier ou les chinois
je pense que tout ça n'est pas n'est pas
très gênant je pense que ces gens vont
livrer une des positions extrêmement
calibre écart a été fait avec leur
conseiller ils seront très à l'aise ils
seront magnifiques dans le recueillement
la compassion on a fait tout ce qu'on a
pu les services français c'est
magnifique tatatata et la marge et j'ai
fait venir tous les chefs d'état oui oui
bon attends je me trompe peut-être
serait une erreur de ne pas les faire
venir justement mais on a gagné une
semaine
les premières plaidoiries sont cent en
avril
c'est les avocats des parties civiles
qui vont être mangés plaidoirie a330
donc je sais pas comment ils vont se
débrouiller je pense qu'ils vont
s'entendre ils sont obligés de
s'entendre parce qu'on peut pas
une plaidoirie de partie civile
théoriquement dans le la pureté de
l'exercice c'est un bon jour je suis
maître nageur et je rends représente
monsieur ou madame machin voilà leur
souffrance c'est ça et voulant dit
d'ailleurs ou pas mais ça peut durer un
quart d'heure waimes c'est que c'est que
c'est que les avocats de parties se
vivent comme des auxiliaires de
l'accusation général du ministère public
et croit judicieux de fournir des
démonstrations dont on ne leur demande
pas de la culpabilité des accusés bon
après c'est donc maintenant sa venue un
peu la forme de dérive de la procédure
pénale on fait avec mais après on
attendra surtout des trois magistrats du
ministère public une démonstration très
très forte de la culpabilité ou pas s'il
décide de renoncer à l'un ou à un ou
deux mais deux des accusés ce qui
interroge beaucoup d'internautes c'est
évidemment le travail comme en affaires
les avocats de la défense qui vont
défiler pendant plus de deux semaines à
la barre après tout ce qu'on s'est dit
là même ce matin
ah ben non il ya des choses a plaidé et
tous ne sont pas au niveau alors les
nîmes c'est que vont dire les avocates
salle abdeslam qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
est-ce qu'ils vont plaider la cause
du mal à le croire mais est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir plaider contre leur client
autre chose
comment on défend beaucoup s'interrogent
comment on peut défendre un individu
comme sale abdeslam ça dépend ce que des
individus si l'individu dit vivre dahesh
ça devient très compliqué si l'individu
dit j'y suis pas mais pas de preuve ces
déductions ça se plaide
parmi les accusés il y en a un qui était
à qui on reproche d'avoir fourni des
faux papiers et des les membres du
commando à s'être fourni des faux
papiers auprès d'un réseau de faux
papiers qu'on appelait catalogue un an
de co2 catalogue et qui a été démantelé
mais dans une autre opération ne doit
plus de droit commun cet homme là il dit
que oui la fourmi au format papier mais
qui d'ignorer complètement il croyait
qu'ils étaient des braqueurs le et donc
fourni cd ça se plaide si l'accusation
ne peut pas prouver que cet homme-là a
sciemment fourni des faux papiers à des
terroristes il peut pas être condamné
pour une association de malfaiteurs
terry sera condamné pour avoir trafiqué
des papiers d'identité ce qui reste
interdite ça ça se plaide 6,1 des indes
accueilli dean mais attendez je suis ici
on appris parce que on a on a un grand
filet mais moi je suis au courant de
rien je ne savais pas non mais ça se
paye il ya un des accusés renvoyer
simplement pour avoir convoyé abdeslam
de paris en belgique il encourt six ans
de détention on lui il peut espérer
toute façon un résultat on sait pas
après les avocats après ça veut dire si
c'est pas non plus voyez il n'y a pas
d'un côté les victimes il ya une somme
de victimes et ce n'est pas les accuser
yens sommes d'accusés et chacun est
différent des autres et chacun va se
débrouiller après les l'agly en a
certains dont on sait qu'ils ont été en
syrie notamment 1
et qu'on compte a été reconnu sur une
vidéo de dèche on voit des des
terroristes de dèche brûlé vif un pilote
jordanien dans une cage sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de ce truc avaient révulsé
à la planète entière à les accuser
apparemment était là lui ça va être
assez compliqué pour lui de dire qu'ils
n'étaient oignons papillon pas au
courant des opérations de neige
merci beaucoup mais je voudrais le dire
en soufflant d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin en direct pour parler justement de
ces auditions de victimes et proches des
victimes des auditions qui vont se
succéder pendant les cinq prochaines
semaines pendant ce procès du 13
novembre merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi sur figaro life lefigaro.fr et
youtube à très vite sur figaro live